trailer drop scary stories to tell in
the dark not going to waste any more
time
I know how you feel
[Music]
Scarecrow
[Music]
[Music]
hey never woke up this story messed me
Oh
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Dunston a mountain worked on this - not
bad I know we normally shout out our
patreon page at the top of the videos
but check out our patreon page we do
weekly Q&A is we also do TV show stream
along for many shows that includes did
all of attack on Titan Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood my hero academia
one punch man John does the haunting of
Hill House he's almost done with that
and Gotham it's in Supernatural and we
do how do reaction highlights included
for several shows that includes one
punch man Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood supernatural and my hero
academia don't get too mad at us now cuz
we waited till after the reaction okay
whoa yeah okay I I haven't read any of
scary stories to tell in the dark I
didn't see any of the Super Bowl spots
either so this was all brand-new footage
for me okay please let me go first since
I know you actually grew up on the
iconic book series
I'm I'm loving the aesthetic to it the
period piece tales are we're getting
here and you know like similar to have
it's funny how it CBS films and you know
that Twilight Zone with Jordan Peele
which feels very like Jordan peels touch
on it and then you got this one which
really feels
Guillermo del Toro's yeah yeah cuz I
love the the designs that feel like a
guillermo del toro design here you know
like the got a mixture of a lot of cool
practical creatures that are infused and
i say i don't know how much of this
looks like just del Toro's designs or
what it didn't I know he doesn't
specifically do them but he works with
people or does this just look exactly
like the book but this is an ethologist
I'm assuming yeah I mean the books there
are three books to my knowledge and
they're all just a collection of short
stories each so each one is a page or a
few pages long as most there are some
really chilling illustrations and
they're there on a youth level so
they're kind of simple in their
construction well it kind of seems like
there might be some cereal storytelling
here though because I wasn't the
impression I would just be strict like
kind of like our Malou are I know ghosts
not ghostbusters goosebumps was a came
out around the same time that was more
kid-friendly
and this was you know this was kids but
it was still much darker but my
understanding is kid accessible but
chilling in a whole other way whereas
like goosebumps are like an adventure
but also kind of scary whereas these I
remember being just scare and also again
the images helped a lot yeah and it's
funny that you bring up goosebumps
because even though this looks like it
has a more sinister a more overtly
horror-movie tone true I do get a
certain similar vibe in the construction
because you know goosebumps is about
them finding RL Stein's books and
unleashing them on the world and this
seems as though it's about a bunch of
the characters and ghouls from the book
coming to life and you know hunting
these kids and you know the various
scenarios that we saw in those stories
playing out at least and it's funny cuz
I have seen the Super Bowl spots and
this is comprised mostly of those yeah I
mean and the thing is again the
illustrations in those books are one of
the things that people take the most
from it because they are horrifying and
actually it seems like they are doing a
pretty good job of basing the creature
designs on those illustrations and and I
can definitely see like why Guillermo
del Toro was called to this because of
that aspect that it is a bit more
straight horror with a certain whimsy
about it but it's not at least as I
remember it gonna pull the punch so much
as maybe a goosebumps might you know
where were goosebumps might compensate
by being like fun yeah is this going on
the CBS streaming service I don't know I
thought this was for theaters I mean
this seems like a full on oh it's a
movie yeah yeah I thought it was a show
Hey oh damn I'm gonna do the wrong
impression the entire time yes the thing
too is the stories themselves at least
as I remember them it's been a while
since I've read one but they are slight
CBS film yeah yeah yeah but but I mean
it is similarly drawing from an
anthology of sorts but yeah and and I
also to appreciate that they got the
director of troll hunter for this
because troll hunter has a certain it's
not like this at all okay it has a
certain aspect of whimsy while also
being kind of a very immediate found
footage for removing well this then
seems a little bit more like a harder
our version I don't know if it's our but
if you I get it already vibe to be pg-13
I think well I get a much darker version
from what the goosebumps movie yeah was
yes in that movie with the books coming
to life and that's kind of what's going
on here at least what's communicated me
in this trailer
you got the mysterious mansion yeah yeah
yeah well goosebumps to was not a
success so maybe this will be the way to
reinvigorate what's the story with the
zit oh the red that's one of the most
infamous ones basically this girl I
think her name is Ruth she gets bitten
by a spider like well in the bath or
something any others read well it starts
to grow in her face or no she's in the
bath and then the welts bursts and a
bunch of baby spiders come out because
it wasn't a spider bite spider laid eggs
in her face that happens when I when I
shaved down down there yeah just all
over your junk
yeah that's creepy and it's weird that
you're a label there you know well there
are my friends now yeah I know it's like
crabs I know the other thing I think is
funny too is they got I mean Guillermo
del Toro co-wrote this with
Milton and Marcus Dunstan who are the
guys who took over saw after part three
and who wrote and directed the collector
in the collection together gotcha and at
least the collector movies I thought
were pretty clever so I feel like this
in the writing Department especially
will probably lead with its horror
inclinations as opposed to a goosebumps
yeah yeah yeah I like the throwback
horror vibe that we're getting here it
feels kind of classical and its
aesthetic the cinematography looks
excellent was kind of reminded me of the
imagery of haunting of Hill House
actually yeah yeah it's kind of or the
house itself reminds me of American
Horror Story - yeah yeah that's I mean
there's a lot there's a lot of callbacks
to a lot of different types of elements
here which I feel is appropriate for the
very limited knowledge I have whose
scary storytelling but I'm excited for
this this is crazy
yeah the one thing I want now I need
this is just a teaser but the one thing
I want now is to get a better sense for
what the through line of the story is
gonna be like I'm really happy to see
these creatures from my you know
nightmares of old come to life you know
I think those parts are gonna be really
cool and you've got built-in fanservice
there but you know given the scary
stories to tell in the dark is not one
story the biggest question mark for me
is what our central characters are gonna
be doing what the plot is gonna be like
how the ghouls are gonna figure it well
now I'm kind of wondering if this is
gonna be an anthology film yeah cuz it
looked it looks like an anthology film
to me of sort it's the impression I'm
getting I can't tell if it's a creep
show or a trick-or-treat
I get what you dad yeah what I'm
wondering yeah I I'm getting a vibe just
because it doesn't look like it's all in
the same time period yeah so I'm getting
the vibe that it's more of a creep show
all within this feel like it's kind of a
hybrid yeah yeah it's all in the same
town you know and this is kind of cool
because I recently watched this nothing
like if I recent watch tales from the
hood okay which is all in the same town
at night in like horror stories and
stuff oh no it's the same scary stories
to tell me yeah I guess you know the
kind of the cast here yeah it's gonna be
all about white issue
suburban white blonde girls who can't
look good because I gotta sit on their
prom today
Instagram and social media it's very
relevant so it's going on today
having ones it is a lot like having
spiders just pour out of your eyes you
know it's horror I feel you there I feel
you there well and we haven't had a very
successful anthology like film shown one
Google search away from knowing for sure
either way it's gonna be multiple
stories it's good it's called scary
stories to tell in the dark I consider
trick-or-treat to be an anthology and
and we haven't had a like financially
successful anthology horror film on a
big scale yeah for quite some time now
it's been a long time
yeah and it's cool to see that this one
is getting the hype it's getting because
I want anthology horror to make a big
leap to the screen again I want it to
like cuz Creepshow is something I grew
up on that a love trick-or-treat was
like a such a disappointment that it
didn't get the mainstream success at a
ditch or it's God's call following we
love that movie but what gets me excited
is this could if this does well we might
even see more anthology kind of horror
films yeah and also just on a side note
like again I don't know exactly which
audience they're pitching this for but I
do like the inclusion of more youth
oriented horror true you know like I
think that's a valuable place to explore
to that yeah kind of
especially after getting goosebumps
which was very comedic and enhancing
it's very horror that's awesome alright
guys well you excited for scary stories
to tell in the dark what's your favorite
story that they tell in the dark do you
have a scary story I'd like to tell in
the dark
do you like the dark subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell we'll catch you guys soon